this past weekend is brought to you by
skills share skill share is an online
learning community for creators or
creators with more than 25,000 classes
in design business and more you'll
discover countless ways to fuel your
curiosity creativity and career if
there's something even pondering
something inside of your soul you want
to do would work you want to do
metallurgy you can do it you can take
classes in social media marketing mobile
photography creative writing or even
illustration whether you're looking to
discover a new passion start a side
hustle or gain new professional skills
skills share is there to keep you
learning thriving and reaching those new
goals join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today
with a special offer just for our
listeners get two months of skill share
for free that's right skills share is
offering this past weekend listeners two
months of unlimited access to over
25,000 classes for free
to sign up go to Skillshare comm slash
Theo von again go to Skillshare comm
slash Theo von to start your two months
now
that's Skillshare comm slash Theo von
tonight he will be at The Whisky in West
Hollywood California and then tomorrow
May 17th he'll be at the monarch theater
in Phoenix Arizona
he has a new single out right now called
dreamland by Dale D'Antoni he's
one-of-a-kind he's that he's that
watermelon water moccasin and he is the
most requested guest that we've had for
this past weekend ladies and gentlemen
riff-raff in a long time man got a heavy
coat of sports gloss oh yeah you look
flossing but you look like a dude that
just got out of Rambo seven oh man
Okeechobee one kenobi out here man you
look like a guy if somebody had a cheat
code in Double Dragon and they got to
use an ultimate character man Tony hey
men do rocked that million-dollar mullet
mr. riffraff Jody High Roller here today
Dale Dan Tony how are you man Rambo oh
dude who you've been fighting man
fighting life putting it in a damn
Lamborghini leglock it's baby dark arts
after dark dude so I got turned on you
from simon rex man he's such a nice guy
that's what you say yeah okay you might
you don't you never you don't no no I
want the other side of the co you want
the other you want the daughter the dark
side of their dark side like that dark
dirt
I want that dirty soil brother teluk
weird when I first moved to LA before I
move yeah you should move out you should
move out here you move out here yeah I'm
like I'm hype double like Hollywood life
and getting ready you go you know I mean
you see the glitz and the glamour
putting on lotion all cut anning those
two puts it makes you dark while you
sleeping looks you get barricades your
pores with did you see the butterscotch
babes you think are you thinking the
Hollywood you're thinking the stars are
all aligned oh you got tits in your
brain so I go so he was all cool at
first once I finally went out there to
live he's like yeah you sure you could
stay with me and I'm like okay well I
mean sure I could find a place and
everything I'll hang out there you know
I mean so I'm like okay cool I'm
thinking like you don't get there you
had lunch with you or what when I didn't
even ask him how many rooms you about
seven or eight rooms cuz he said he
stayed up in the hills
yeah I've never been there but I heard
he so he had out yeah he had a house up
there in the hills and I think like a
few houses down was Cindy Crawford as a
house all right so so man his house
a jerk-off on the street if Cindy
Crawford lived by me and now yeah so he
he has me moving I think i'ma stay on
the couch or one of his rooms or
something he had he had a downstairs
there's like a three-story house so you
go downstairs and then down there's a
wine cellar and he's like you can have
this room but I've seen these racks on
the well I'm like this is no this isn't
a room yeah it is for great yeah this
for sun-dried grapes for aged prune yeah
so I go to in there then I have a room
and I'm thinking he let he didn't let me
go parties wouldn't let me come upstairs
cuz there was a door the lock he'd love
to have the part up seeing the people
come in you had to stay down there stay
down maybe like a Notre Dame like that
guy that rings the bell I'm no time
though I didn't know I'll be answering
the door and that's about it
yeah I thought I was gonna get to party
with the Hollywood star I am you know
who came through there all types of
people hung Bill Cosby Reynolds Burt
Reynolds Wow yeah yeah Kevin Costner
I've seen in now you know everybody yeah
a Jim Thome Dan you know Jim Thome
Chipper Jones stopped by a couple times
Jesus yeah and who else even I heard
that they had Daffy Duck past there no
no more ghosts Garciaparra he go he
ghosted me a couple times on the
handshake on the way out yeah so I was
trying to catch girls coming out try
talked to him that binge on the show but
he didn't have any lights down there for
me on purpose so I couldn't I couldn't
talk to nobody so I don't want to hear I
don't want to hear I didn't know him
then yeah we had a hat and I had to pay
2,700 month uh-huh I stay there about
two weeks I kept my deposit I cleaned
the place yeah yeah so so that's the
other side of where that's the dirty
side of that that's the dark side do we
both grew up in a different time I feel
like oh yeah no real time the 18 I'm
fine yeah a day woody
what do you love about it with some that
you miss about it I think I think people
if they saw more clearly yeah you know
me I'm sweating like a damn gesundheit
oh yeah all sports gloss oh I'm sweating
like a [ __ ] sneeze stuck in a thick
[ __ ] you feel me I'm [ __ ] yeah yeah
I'm creating yeah we're dripping dude I
was dripping like a [ __ ] like an
Icelandic stripper bro in a [ __ ]
Sunstone yeah
Bobby we were playing sports yeah okay
so first of all the reason what yeah I'm
sweating it's because talking about
building a five-acre football field
sports sports compound get away from the
world I think I think in the back in the
80s there you couldn't you couldn't
direct message Elvis Presley you
couldn't hit up Roseanne Barr yeah I
couldn't got a comment under a rod
stewart and say hey yeah I don't want to
live forever young yeah oh you're too
old to be thinking about me yeah yeah
yeah you couldn't talk to people I think
and now the with like media and all the
online say stimulus extremely yeah now
the online is turned into the National
Enquirer remember you'll be I'll be
aligned my mom grocery shopping yeah and
I look over the Ronald Reagan pregnant
would triplet yeah Ronald Reagan got a
slave and you're like what yeah I was I
was back in the head we were we were at
a place called Garland's yeah there was
a store and I'd be in line they would
there be a black and white newspaper at
the Ashland quarren is a it would say
like Abraham Lincoln found 50 50 gold
coins under Abraham Lincoln found
cave-dwelling yeah Abraham Lincoln found
out how to cook cook canned fish I get
it that's not real like damn yeah aliens
uh they have David have a rumor like
aliens at the arm they would have aliens
at the [ __ ] Lakeland mall you don't
sign yeah - aliens found at lake level
so so nowadays anybody you could say
anything if it's juicy enough then
people you could did a blog right and
then also I get yeah do you ever get
direct message crazy direct messages
from home man yeah you know cuz they get
they got they got direct message then
they have requests so so every now and
then I dabble in there look people tell
you can you post my Kickstarter I'm
trying to be a rapper hey you inspired
me to be a rapper back it
ouu inspired me to get up in the morning
you know I mean so now now it's
everything you hear yeah everybody ever
ever and everybody is you inspired me to
be just like you people think that it's
like well I'll take a picture with you
then I get some of your magical powers
and like it's not magical powers it's
just I'm like you know they like
accessible you think it's too accessible
to reach somebody that I think I think
with Instagram just like you know you
had a verified account right yeah I
think every single human being who's on
in scream just like how you got to be
verified to make sure that you everybody
should be very proud of me for that you
should send in your you should first of
all to be able to direct message
somebody should have to be 18 and up
yeah and if you honor that's it then
your parents should be have their credit
card online if you put and leave a
comment that's vulgar then Instagram
should shut your account until they the
customer service can FaceTime you and
talk to you and your parents would be
like if you leave another comment first
of all you find 50 bucks yeah if they
find your parents - so you're monitoring
that credit card your ma knows
immediately and they're finding you but
see over there on all Jase 80 if you
were if you're in school and you say
some [ __ ] you get in trouble then you
should get in trove that you people say
oh I don't like this on but then yeah
you know if you say miss oniton is fat
then you get in trouble that's 39 you
know I'm saying yeah yeah whatever
exactly if you should be people should
be able to have to watch the people
Sheriff or watch what they say and why
is that okay so if the people if
Instagram such a big thing it's big
because of what just people want to see
the inside scoop violence on celebrities
live or whoever right so every single
celebrity everything a verified account
was be like you know what I'm a boycott
Instagram get out of there there's just
all these regular people just not even
regular people but you know people who
aren't an unverified account on verified
accounts we're just going to each other
wouldn't that wouldn't exist right but
do you think I mean I mean it's gonna be
me saying it's gonna be something had to
be somebody big Steven Tyler it's gonna
have to be wealthy exactly alarm strong
yeah David Duchovny would have to say
some [ __ ] the what I'm saying right now
for it to matter but yeah I'd have to
give you should have to be a black yeah
it Bill Cartwright or uh I'm trying to
think of something John Salley would
have
John John Salley why don't everybody
love John Salley man yes I think if
people think he's our senior Hawes older
brother yeah it was like okay you know
yeah he's our senior tall bro he's like
the [ __ ] jolly Shack would have to say
some did I saw Shaq man he's everywhere
I saw him two weeks ago to UFC fight
okay blew my mind you're bidding UFC
fights I don't think I've been to a live
one
have you ever been approached about
being a wrestler yeah actually no
[ __ ] um Hulk Hogan when I started
cuz like for a time I was like trying to
just put on as much weight as possible
yeah cuz you definitely you look thick
man you look like Lyle Alzado before the
disease no for since I've been in
Florida I've lost like almost 30 pounds
I was like 250 but I was just trying to
bulk up right but now in the in this I'm
sweating right now like it's muggy like
in Houston but you you just naturally if
you're outside you're gonna just
naturally just not want it cuz it's so
hot out you're gonna want to eat
hamburgers and french fries outside you
know I mean I just my appetite slowed
down and my hunger for working out
increased really since you've been here
I've been out here like six months
building this studio yeah man this that
magma molten the first you know my
person here so let yeah you're the first
human to be in this facility your honor
no joke yeah really do man
yeah such a big thing you're the most
requested person ever of any dude of
anybody alive or dead bruh Lyle's no
body I'm Jefferson
not that many hits yeah anybody dude
everybody I think we're the only mullet
barring municipal yeah marsupials yeah
brah I mean we definitely those [ __ ]
hair bears you know we're up there yeah
the hair bears the [ __ ] afghanistan's
bro we got that [ __ ] I got I got the
damn floor to follicle fountain back you
don't mean we're in riffraff Ganis tan
brothers in the neon neon nightmare
sports studio we're showcasing sports
dude you got the ghost of Tony Gwynn of
Tony Gwynn house
yeah I got Kirby Pucket oh you got Cecil
fielding out here feel they're still
working the big one oh yeah you got the
big Union I got Randy Johnson head out
back yard mulch oh yeah molten mullets
he got him out there he's doing he's
putting he put in he's investing in some
type of planner II now he had good hair
he had a nice set backstage how do you
feel differently now that you had the
million-dollar mullet because Dale
D'Antoni and he only comfortable because
I'd had like a full head of just hair
for like I'd had braids for almost like
ten years just I just you know I mean oh
yeah man you said hey and I could still
grow it out if I want to but I keep it's
just like when it's when it's not
hitting your ears and you know I mean
like the hair getting your mouth and
start like having this front trimmed up
and then the back you know I mean it's
just a lot easier wash is easier to dry
mm-hmm it looks better people see it's a
no yeah it sounds better yeah when it's
in the wind it has a certain sound to it
whispering around has a snap yeah you
know I mean I think that's where the
rice krispy those rice krispies treat
those three I think they had mullets
they made him cut him when they were
getting but that's like I got that snap
crackle pop oh dude look man if you if
you look at old pictures of him boys all
three of them mm-hmm you know and one of
them had an arm was a celiac had celiac
disease wasn't the red-haired boy I
think it was because one who couldn't
even eat the treats they made oh wow and
that really I know that hurt a lot of it
didn't hurt people's feelings but you
know anyway it was so him even being
able to be a part of it was really a
miracle yeah but yeah they uh they all
had mullets when they were younger
that's funny you knew that yeah I've had
a feeling who would be the top let's do
the top five people that should have
mullets because it would change how they
[ __ ] on right now yeah okay well you
go first okay first up if I had to think
of a good person that could get a mullet
cuz it would help him I think operate a
little bit better and really show who he
is I go with bill trill Clinton damn you
think he'd go back running for prayers
oh did I think he'd [ __ ] run through
a couple more legs opposed if he [ __ ]
threw wondered cuz bill man I've been
through Arkansas and he they said you
know a lot of ladies still know him and
remember him fondly
and I think if he had a mullet it would
really take it to the next level you go
all white or let her diet I don't know I
don't know if Hillary would let him died
I think you'd have to go yeah she'd
probably kick him out that day back on
your old [ __ ] again ain't you yeah get
out of hole Arkansas you're gonna make
me look bad in front of my peers you
having peace my state then they get into
it cuz he got that fire back enemy if I
recall correctly you didn't even even
pick me yeah I think you you picked
another man you picked that guy who did
the arm the Pete Herman cane you was
[ __ ] jock and Herman cane back in a
day Pizza Pizza Pizza
you want it you wanna do you really want
a Billy Mays yeah yeah you'll pick him
for Foursquare ball yeah yeah you want
it uh um you want a Billy Ray Cyrus I
saw you looking at his [ __ ] overall
strap I saw I saw you over there looking
at his Instagram stores yeah I was over
your shoulder yeah I saw you reading
[ __ ] cornbread recipes that his
mother I've written yeah yeah yeah you
cared more about him you don't even
[ __ ] care about me you don't Hillary
input you know when you a baby you had
Teddy Ruxpin you put a tape in the back
and it was just his voice uh-huh just
cradling you to sleep audio cradles yeah
you got audio cradles from mom Billy
Mays back there yeah you had a Teddy
Ruxpin trying to sell you a [ __ ]
OxiClean yeah no wonder you can't get
any rest at night you know who I think
should should should film more movies
who I think Adams sounding should grow
mullet and really just get ripped and
just showcasing shoot happy gilmore -
yeah I can see that boy how happy is how
I wonder what it would be called happier
now yeah happier than ever happier now
and I would like to even see him being a
wheel chair in Jack this [ __ ] because if
you here's the thing I noticed I got a
couple buddies that was when a guy got
hit by lightning or fell into a hole or
something
and another guy his legs never he never
had any good legs from the beginning
right and so he's all Jat when you just
focus on the upper body mm-hmm
like on hand we got height lights-out
but his dude is so [ __ ] jacked man
it's a different level you know but I
could see that Adam Sandler if he had a
nice mullet what kind of good movies
would he make different ones he should
he should to retake over Rambo because I
know that shooting a Rambo but what if
they switched up went by Rambo eight and
it was it was two Rambo's it was me me
and Adam sands yeah well I would erase
II that Horatio Sanz or Horatio Sandler
uh uh Norma Connell should grow mullet
and just get ripped oh yeah and he's
like yeah yeah he does a Colonel Sanders
movie but it's a documentary but it's
all way off in the Colonel Sanders is
his twin brother yeah yeah and him and
Colonel Sanders fight and then he beats
Colonel Sanders and opens up a place
called norm MacDonald's and it's a
[ __ ] place we were to seize on yeah
so I take over McDonald's yeah so no
trademark infringement issues and you go
in there you think you're gonna get
something eaten it's Norma Donald in
there with a [ __ ] just with a hatch
that are just [ __ ] you up crank and
chords dude how much I can't believe
nobody's funding this [ __ ] we got I
don't sound could do it you know I can't
know about I can't believe we can't
anybody to fund these ideas all right so
you got it we got Bill Clinton we got
out of Sandler but dude I heard they're
making Tran bow it's like a trans
transgender bollocks
Oh flex em pay you know flex it makes
you dick wet yeah both flicks sent me a
free Bowflex
here it's in the bad yard Wow I'm
serious I thought I thought you know my
friend of mine his sister hooked up with
Tony Little from Tony Little gizelle
freestyler from the commercials yep
who's a long time ago not friend Erin
you don't know him he he used to live my
me when I was younger um you know I got
a [ __ ] from Jared from Subway sister
a long time ago in the French Quarter
damn okay so we got Bill Clinton Adam
Sandler I think think of somebody good
news I think Ricki Lake should come back
with her own show and she's just she's
molded out and she's like listen I'm
gonna tell y'all what's cool what's not
cool y'all are just not y'all ain't it
yeah this is what this is what's going
on this is cool and she just does a
whole show on this is cool this ain't
yes and she just airs everybody out puts
it all out she's like listen cuz she's
mixed first of all so she could talk
[ __ ] by everybody and then she got yeah
then she have the side slashes - she
does
she should that thicky Lake they used to
call her cuz she got dick for a while
and she just she's just in there with
the mullet and she's just sitting there
and she's dancing and everything but not
regular like Ellen dances like just
moving and it's easygoing now she's rich
she's out there getting it and she's
she's telling that everybody now this is
this is where it's at yeah yeah y'all
need to quit [ __ ] driving this uh
this Toyota Camry ain't it listen these
super Oh hatchbacks [ __ ] hatchback
brah what you need is to get that for
fest even put some [ __ ] 38s on it
damn what the hell were them things
called Suzuki truce troopers yeah but
you got to get a real Asian marinated
snap things on it yeah that was like the
the windbreaker of course yeah you like
damn this thing doubles as a [ __ ]
light coat yeah you wear that damn that
click they let them one of them snaps
slope yeah dude
oh if you got cold out man goes if it up
turn the heat on leave it leave the car
run about 30 minutes later heat up take
the key go right around a black hole
either heat cranking dude it was it was
like a windbreaker someone you find
something in the pocket of the doors
they was like a pot it was like it's so
stretchy yeah you found a your old
credit card in error or a stick of gum
and just a silly straw yeah - another
key one that somebody been chewing on
the Frog on the time got a green one
ma'am yeah Ricki Lake would be really
good if she grew her hair out she needs
to do that good more people were respect
her too I think she needs to make a
comeback coming back I'll do motor
combat seonyu are the barstool sports
they anytime somebody gets a mullet they
post it mm-hmm anytime and do you feel
like people I notice a lot of people
come to me with it
but in you know in other countries and I
know you know in other countries this is
just a hockey haircut or it's a in some
countries in Amsterdam this is a woman's
haircut this is predominantly a young
woman and a lot of times if it's a young
white girl that dates a lot of brothers
don't have this hair you know jewelry is
jewelry but diamonds are diamonds yeah
you know I mean a lot of people can
mistake something for one thing just cuz
old cars the cars were Lamborghini
Lamborghini yeah
and I'll talk about that forest light
but when you have the mullet and you get
you're doing it the million dollar
mullet mm-hmm that's a whole other you
know that's a whole other station for
that hair that's a whole other station
verification and it looks strong it
looks like the back is on creating yeah
I mean I mean III hate to take this out
and I'll throw my damn yeah I'd love to
see a little more you know this isn't
this isn't know that people ask if I
have a zipper on it yeah that ain't no
sipping tea huh haha dude that's like
that [ __ ] Jim McMahon huh remember
him who was the guy that played uh Brian
Bosworth Brian Bosworth man you know
yeah the Xavier McDaniel what the pant
with the back Panhandle yeah man
that's that yeah that's that really
that's that [ __ ] uh that's that
Rapunzel man hey I soaked this sweat
band
it's that bra Ponzo colors bleeding too
would have so much sports gloss look at
we're outside playing sports that's a
mission tuck was telling about the those
five acres you don't want to talk about
your dog look man you have I know you
have a lot of beautiful animals here and
honestly I was scared of the animals cuz
I seen him on the internet a long time
ago I saw that man this man have a lot
of animals did I grew up in like a stray
animal area okay we're back in the 80s
of the never stray animals yeah there
are out there this is out member that
you go outside I got two animals out
there brothers walking around yeah they
got a hall yeah and there was one linger
around the neighborhood there but I just
left in there
nobody called nothing there was nobody
call control what time you get yeah you
got a house phone no area code what time
you got back inside you forgotten you're
getting up a bomb stick out of freezer
oh yeah
you [ __ ] laughs out on a bomb pop run
a couple episodes of [ __ ] uh Cosby or
Family Matters bob bobbi's world oh do
different world member different world
growth going to college growing pains
yeah oh did I wanted that got to be my
daddy I wanted a boner
oh you can't name it any my boner on TV
no more that's uh not anymore man member
those days yeah well you you if you
wanted to know what was going on you can
watch the news what you didn't have to
and it was on it for one hour yeah now
it's everything his news people watch TV
because they had a show they want to
watch oh seven o'clock I'm watching cops
eight up yeah eight o'clock I'm watching
current affairs yes
nine o'clock over at my dad's like
everybody believed the TV I'm watching
Mary with children yes you know I mean
there were holes in the back of my leg
or like WWF there's like one night Oh
much yeah we got about ten thirty on
you're not a midnight to see that it was
like any other than that Friday you go
okay look go in a blockbuster everybody
pick one movie yeah you know I mean and
now everybody I know it's just
everything is news like back in the day
it was everybody would fight for who
could be the coolest you know I was
fighting for who can who could be the
best now it's who can be the victim
fastest yeah shameless oh and people
confuse Fame and talent with victimhood
yeah hey hey no no he did it oh yeah
you're doing something hey whoa well he
also did this yeah he did something else
- yeah cut orange and actually in in
back of the day that didn't matter like
if some of us are like tarnish you
didn't matter
yeah but now the person who was trying
to throw dirt on your name they could
make up anything hey Theo von stole my
truck last night he drove over to Arby's
yeah he got 15 Bronco Bears
stepped on smashed him it splattered all
over my seats yeah and then I'm the
headline man who had 15 splattered yeah
Bronco berries look officer say look how
sad it is he's so tough on me now people
go fund me in for a new sheepskin take
Theo wants sweaters you can't wear a
shirt ever again man it's so saying man
yeah now it's like oh who can be the
best victim who can be the best well
well well um [ __ ] I don't have shoes
yeah oh man that's so sad man dude when
I was gonna remember Shoeless Joe
Jackson was a was a star because he did
a whole that was his thing a sport
without having shoes now is just
somebody without shoes yeah they have
shoes in the locker they leave them in
there just to go out there and be like
yeah now somebody forgot their
combination got my shoes give me a
contract yeah that's what people think
is now you go on but here's here's where
I think that the line is still drawn so
that's early Fame that's people reach
and pets people doing that but then you
still have to get on stage and bring a
type of magic oh yeah and the shoe now I
remember one time I was on tour I was
actually working with Noor McDonald I
was in Oklahoma and they hey used to
have a dude on America's Got Talent or
something pants on the ground
remember this guy pants on the ground
look like a fool Japan ground now this
was a guy who you know had a you know he
had issues but gravity and he [ __ ]
didn't have a belt right yeah so this
guy they brought him out to the show he
opened the show up doing five minutes
pants on the ground then he brought his
dime out there he had a lady in her
pants had issues as well so he bring out
their do five more minutes you know what
I'm saying brawl on the [ __ ] table or
something you know bro on the table row
on the table if I can't find him from a
pierced navel cuz the bras on okay so
then and their big closer they were both
kind of lay on the ground and [ __ ]
take off the bra or something I don't
know right yeah but that dude had two
months of work and and the rest of us
who were doing comedy are still doing it
right so there is that line where
you take it to the stage there's that
long yeah and yeah the trends and the
fads right those will face the trends
and fads will fade and some people
evolve in the create new way that's why
I say separation by elevation right you
know me you got it right like you know
that's the one thing but you got to get
it there's a lot of grabbers these days
oh for sure yeah there's always
something new yeah there's always gonna
be a new toy in the store it's always
gonna be new snacks to come out and
they're in the front from the store
they're trying to sell you know but
they're but then put them Cool Ranch
Doritos all remember when they came out
those cool ran straight days well yeah
I'm everyone looking the commercials for
[ __ ] was just wave different boat like
when Bowl Jax was playing two sports
playing two sports and mike tyson and
when a when the the double decker taco
and you had the double decker taco
sideways Nick yeah I remember Denny
Talkeetna Shaq would head sideways and
that he couldn't eat he couldn't live as
well shoe frito yeah
do you remember how good remember
remember when cool restaurateurs number
of cuts for 20 years it was just Doritos
cheese on regular nothing thing you saw
them Cool Ranch and then Sunday but
there wasn't good ranch it was cool damn
and it felt good on you everybody wanted
the cool ring oh dude they were so loud
they didn't have never wear I remember
biking all around town we heard that
they had him somewhere dude a friend of
mine got hit by a Trans Am on his bike
looking for Cool Ranch Doritos bra and
was on a [ __ ] wheelchair that hug
what they called slush puppies slush
puppies and Cool Ranch Doritos need then
go in there what did you use to a
regular summer day as a kid hmm how like
what kind of like you go to a gas
station out where did you get your money
first of all okay first of all we got
the money was my mom had a chart if you
were good you started out with a dollar
at the beginning of the week alright and
you got checks on there when you were
bad so everybody got checks and you
ended up at about 20 cents my little
sister though she was always sick so she
got all her money because she couldn't
do anything bad she was ill so then we
would get her money - me and my brother
would take bar her money from her right
and break each other off 50 cent each so
I'd roll out at about 60 cents over to
that 7-eleven
get myself [ __ ] two packs a garbage
pail kid cards bro
I'm saying cuz I start around my boys
remember that loogie Larry
oh yeah Nia just [ __ ] slow yeah
snotty Scotty Oh remember BOM Tom and
his head of an atomic atomic atom atomic
add atom yeah they had a Twisted Sisters
and they were like two snakes Twitter's
and yet they had on oh they had flat Pat
it was just a doodle steamroll yeah yeah
yeah
they had um trim Tim and he was getting
that [ __ ] tight hair yeah you're
getting a haircut with the scissors like
when Thor was cut his ear and cut his
neck yeah over oh right razor ah whoo
yeah
first fans like it was back when it was
license yeah and he cut his wrists or
something brung in a capture that sad
with sideways for attention horizontal
to get the job done all right well I
didn't know what that meant when I was 8
11 I was like okay yeah I just continued
yes some were a little dark like I feel
yeah kill yourself Randall and you're
like what the wait those don't even
rhyme start with the same he's just
hanging in a closet you know you're like
damn this [ __ ] is dark
quaalude [ __ ] Donald damn and he just
have a couple pills and his kids are
[ __ ] crying by the cops
ghostly George he's just hanging himself
hey hangman Hank he was hanging herself
in front of the students he was
substitute teacher like damn first day
just got a hurry I would get that and
they had a fireball bra and that was the
thing if you wanted to flex a little bit
in front of your boys or two chicks oh
yeah bit you wanted to get that fireball
show up with that red that lusciousness
kind of hmm and had that heat in your
mouth man and that was about just
sticking to the side and it's a longer
burn and they knew you could [ __ ] if you
had that piece in there and you get that
that thing was about a nickel and you
put that thing in you don't show up mom
so I'll do that and then if I had a
little bit extra money then I would get
myself maybe a chocolate for at night
getting myself a KitKat
and they have four pieces in there
sometime I would get my mom my um payday
candy bar and I was kind of like an ice
candy bar they had back then right now
in nature's own they got all these fancy
ones but back then they had that payday
and it was for smart people right but it
was different man what would you get if
you think you know well I just out first
I had this little bronze like glass like
little jar and I went off filled up
about sell I sell lemonade oh wow I mean
yeah me and my sister herself like ten
cents five said whatever whatever you
had until it fills up the jar so I just
go back in and keep making it I just
wanted to fill that job and how many
used Selleck warts gallons cards so
until was gone yeah I keep going back
and make some more if I need to I wanted
to fill that jar oh yeah I sold three
cents yeah as long as it's filled up so
you got you know you gotta fill it up
yeah yeah that's that feeling the roller
they put then go pull up into but then
you got you take that jar mm-hmm just
shove it in my pocket that's a lot of
money right now go up to the public pool
hang out see what's going over there oh
that's on the way cuz then he turned and
he go down and there was a circle K okay
so I've done but it wasn't on the street
who's in it right at the end of the
neighborhood so I didn't ever cross the
street so I don't know they're dangerous
right so now what was happening at the
public pool told kids running around
screaming it was a diving board the hot
the hot girl lived behind it oh she
she's had bleach blonde hair oh yeah
holy Sanders who just Colby Sanders on a
Japanese or was she she was black agent
oh you came to say white these days yeah
you can get hogtied and stripped of all
your medals be saved color yeah so she
was on a Norton Norwegian Nordic descent
right you'd have to ask her what she is
yeah yeah exactly I don't even know I
was up well I get sued for even
mentioning a human and I think that's
how it works these days so yeah then
there's a diving board yeah I can just
hear it now you know and there's the
deep end yeah there's the deep end and
then they're just whistles blowing right
and laughs yeah stop and stop breathing
yeah stop breathing yeah yeah yeah I
mean and then you breathing underwater
site
you can close your eyes underwater yeah
stop drowning they would say yeah
there's the outdoor shower you know
people with some family would be in the
corner with their little picnic set up
yeah they have a set up right kind of by
the lifeguard so you can [ __ ] with them
yeah yeah then the older kids down by
the diving board lining up if you were
if you weren't tall enough you you
couldn't you couldn't even go on the
diving board in the deep end
then there's adults swim yeah yeah like
Oh adults women and I'll wait for adults
women out go take off to the gas station
cuz that's when what the kids had to get
out and get out and then go to the
playground or they'd walk around go play
the Ouija board in the bathroom adults
only yeah yeah they go seven seven seven
minutes of heaven over there by the by
the tricycles yeah man it's like yeah
yet to get out yeah so I take off the
gas station they had the the Jolly
Rancher fire the fire Jolly Ranchers
they're called fire flavored there was
cinnamon but they were crazy hot and the
package will be stuck to the sides but
it was molten around it so like it was
there was angles gyah geometry angles on
the things that had melted they it's
been sitting in the hole yeah so you
didn't know you know how to get into
this now you get some little banana
Laffy Taffy's they didn't even have
jokes on them back a day wow you just
had to watch something had to open and
just make up a joke was over hey what do
a police a on their birthday oh no just
give me one know what Apple say on a
birthday oh do what yeah forest fires
are friendly yeah yeah so those and then
uh you get those a little I was like it
looked like a barrel mm-hmm it was a but
it tastes like a melted popsicle it was
a like a little blue juice you know he
was wax no no no I'm talking about yeah
well the carton was yes it's like a look
it's like a barrel and it had a little
metal top yeah you peel that off yeah oh
that [ __ ] was good what was that it's
melted popsicles all the melted
popsicles that go in the stores and they
just put them in the that oh I need to
know I didn't know I didn't know what
either a man that's behind the scene
yeah it has a kick in the back yeah that
[ __ ] get your neck on what it was a
free neck brace man I'm [ __ ] loosen
you up yeah
you got enough Todd double decker taco
oh yeah oh no I'm just saying that the
oh yeah with that one you and a [ __ ]
wheel out of there but do people use to
arm you're at the nurse's office oh yeah
you remember that nurse yeah I knew kids
who used to go to the nurse's office
just to switch clothes with the
lost-and-found just to get a new pair of
pants that pink pants are uh they had to
piss their pants on purpose Brian that's
back when I remember dude I remember I
get a bone or writing go in and a lady
and be like hey something wrong with my
yeah it's out my dick keep getting
hearts a bee stung me that's what I
would tell her yeah well the nurse say I
think she liked me a little bit but I
was young and how was he she was
probably maybe 50 or 48 but her husband
had left her and she had a kid that was
in our class well she can't send you a
note yeah it's the other sick today
sometime I'll be getting hurt I think
feel sick yeah he seems really sick
today
we had some calls we had some questions
that came in from some listeners we'll
go through some ore and we'll try to
answer some of them and see what's going
on did I miss those old days though it's
a different time it's a different time
man different vibe okay here's a white
guy right here you know Theo so you're
doing some [ __ ] on the 80s I want to
know if you guys ever played with the
WWF wrasslers the big rubber ones me my
brother used to beat each other with
them and we would have little makeshift
wrestling matches that we choreographed
it were pretty cool I also would [ __ ]
eat the man I know I eat me a [ __ ]
hillbilly gym arm before I remember they
had like the Mean Gene Okerlund doll and
his back was completely flat and that
was the one that you didn't want to get
hit in the head with because I [ __ ]
had knockout power but uh yeah man I
[ __ ] to enjoy the [ __ ] out of your
[ __ ] comedy man and just listening to
you you [ __ ] have really helped me
I'm like 80 days sober right now and
you're like an inspiration to me so
anyways I think you're a funny
[ __ ]
Gang Gang later Gang Gang but it's nice
of you to say that man why I'm here with
the [ __ ] human highlight right here
in RIF gana Stan dude and do you
remember the wrestlers RIF did you do
head I think I had my favorite ones with
Lee I had Legion of Doom oh yeah they're
the spikes shoulder pads and a hacksaw
jim duggan remember that handicap no it
was a construction worker dont one he
time i was the foam i mean is a rubbery
ones those are the big one you don't
want oh I didn't get that you wanted the
action figures with the mobile arms that
[ __ ] move and they're about this size
yes yes you know that I hated those yes
no those were like those were those were
yeah it doesn't thing but hit somebody
yeah those were like deflated hot water
balloon yeah that other remember uh Big
Boss Man member him now yeah boss man he
was racist now he I think he was racist
but at the time he was just a regular
God that he was trying to earn money for
his family and survive we had to cutoff
sleeves yeah Howard I think across his
[ __ ] chest that he was wah wah but
then he met a black girl and actually it
had a mixed child already on hold he
turned it around but who else member
Coco beware they had a black pulpit
overheard yeah and he would show up yeah
Bret the Hitman Hart haha look let's
talk about you wanna talk about long
years Jimmy Superfly Snuka man that guy
would jump off the thing
you wore the cheetah pants okay yeah and
he killed a woman he'd in real life
yeah he killed a woman here in Florida
actually but who else man man my
favorite was Macho Man Randy Savage
Macho Man Ultimate Warrior yeah Ultimate
Warrior was [ __ ] good bro he even
like I know he died not too long ago
yeah not too long ago man like he was a
legend like I know he was even after he
stopped you know wrestling and he moved
to a ranch a lot of those wrestlers I
learned they moved far far away from
people they want to they get on me a lot
of move the floor
yeah and they get four or five acres you
know me
why do you think that is they want to
just I think it comes apart they prey
prices all what was coming like the two
thousands of like I don't want all that
don't know what that is I don't want
that
oh no no no not that day they they all
like the this do you want I mean to me I
need I need I need I need to create
space right to have to be able to create
I need to create space to have a
creative space oh yeah I'm saying I need
job I need space between yeah yes
everything you need that think area yeah
you need a really you need some acres
for your brain yeah but I mean I but I
know he was probably like I saw like a
documentary was still talking [ __ ] Wow
he cut his hair and everything but he
was just in him that warrior spirit like
he was just he was underdog a lot of hot
dogs vibes with him because he was also
[ __ ] yeah he would always come in and he
always seemed like from parts unknown
and brought thing gets heard saying
about him yeah that he was from he could
that way he could be anybody I know a
lot of people say like some things like
there's a character I don't know but
like I think I mean when is somehow you
like mentally like they're like parts
unknown yeah like that's just what that
is you know I mean that's where they're
from yeah they feel is out of themself
like they aren't from somewhere and they
just all where they are and that's what
yeah and I think that certain people
after you know be a get a certain amount
of space to be me I remember I'm now now
looking back at it I'm starting to see
I'm like kind of like that because in
school I couldn't think about what's on
paper I didn't I don't want to be here
with all these damn bright lights and
wait what time is it
yeah I should be asleep I think kids
should be able to sleep until they wake
up live kids are gonna be home school
your school don't start to teach it or
even get here I'm not calling teacher
over until you wake up yeah you're
growing still your brain isn't even
functioning fully yet you know I mean
you know we got you up at 6:30 in the
morning and then they who knows what
they're feeding them yeah I think the
motor right out of the gate I think I
think until you're about 13 14 you
should be until you're done growing
height-wise you should be sleep you know
you can be on a sleep schedule yeah you
know me but you can't force a kid to go
to sleep I mean in their room plenty I
mean yeah they look important tense
number two I'm looking for someone time
for prowling around six days just
prowling around I didn't sleep for six
of them looking for something man that
I'm [ __ ] needed what was it I don't
know man just looking around
yeah friend a friend's house stay the
night and then you stayed a friend's
house than y'all prowling around the
garage and the gram will come out what
somehow that prowling around you
prowling around the garage get back in
here play RBI Baseball or something I'm
gonna make ya'll some coke floats
what about root beer for Coke floats
over here alright yeah let me get y'all
some water floats never [ __ ] water
doctor Thunder AC on fifty but they say
they're what they save money on the soda
saved twenty cents cut coupons
oh cool people use coupons in the mail
don't even sayin coupons no more I don't
give a [ __ ] if you have a discount what
the [ __ ] is going to have mailbox you
don't get any damn coupon give me the
only thing no good thing is them damn
when you get those [ __ ] little damn
squares of like a you peel off the thing
you put ten CDs that you want on there
and put one penny and you mail those off
that and coupons you should get cool
[ __ ] in the mail now they send you your
[ __ ] they sent you a bank statement
oh [ __ ] wait why is my banks a bank
statement in my in a mailbox that I
didn't even tell you to mail this [ __ ]
yeah and anybody just walking I see I
ever get it get your money get your
information right there I'm gonna cut
I'm gonna take my [ __ ] mailbox out of
the damn ground yeah they say that
peoples identity identity theft
you can [ __ ] go is it sitting in a
box at the end of my coupons yeah
remember a coupons you percent off a
pop-tart so you can even I bet you
there's some CD there's a company code
there's company there's gotta be
companies out there that are sitting on
hundreds and thousands or millions of
Duran Duran CDs soul asylum porno for
Pyro's they're just
sitting on ancient [ __ ] CDs tapes
I'll buy all those for one centerpiece
oh the right now make more out of them
sell them hi I listen I go by a tape
player saw a yellow Sony Walkman [ __ ]
headset I go jogging around listening to
[ __ ] Madonna's greatest hits
oh that jog wire dude I could see you
that cat is loose bro I was just with
the biggest headphones ever brought this
[ __ ] big bro
press down playing recording you put the
tape in the earpiece brother that's how
big the [ __ ] hip bones are damn bro I
could see ya should make those do you
know how many people would love those
put a [ __ ] helmet on with the CD on
top tape player on the side speakers in
there and fresh water in the back AC in
there everybody Slater yeah dude you
literally have a picture of [ __ ]
Mario Lopez on the back dude and he can
hear you and you tell them how cold you
wanted in there dude we should start a
company man that's gonna go along with
we're gonna have okay the five acres
right Vince to round what did you don't
ya honey dollars to get in riff Raff's
got off stop it are you F F stop
riffraff riff rough yeah we're then
puppies can come to play riff Raff's
husky hub in sports you can bring you
it's five so but you can bring your
mobile home bring your dog every item
that comes in there's a 100 bucks an
hour yeah no matter what you breathe
you're bringing your mobile [ __ ] you
bring your four-wheeler bring your
barbecue pit that's 200 now you got oh
you have a husky in a chihuahua ok
another 200 and it's not your own risk
because if husky eats them then they vet
but if you have a pit bull in it attacks
one of the Huskies then you find a
million dollars so right that's that
rule that's your entering you entering
is at your own risk of liabilities ok
that risk item if you want to bring
[ __ ] allen iverson to the beach you
know what I'm saying this guy a batting
cage yeah but with tennis balls to shoot
out of 50 miles per hour
just straight fast balls not crazy
sliders right
in any of your [ __ ] speed [ __ ]
tester with the pitching thing and this
dog and everything the dogs can do it or
what what is it like dogs are running
around five acres and [ __ ] mixing it
up you bring your four-wheeler you're
working that for well they're gonna
chase it and what are the dogs else
today I can excite bike track oh yeah
big pool there what else do they have
for the dog different events or
something yeah I mean there should be uh
it could be a [ __ ] you know what the
football like a dance or something that
night they should be the light-up
squares and they run it on and they
changed some hologram cats they can
chase around foxes you know I mean yeah
I love that Dalmatian station if you
want to go over there and check out some
some tennis ball machine just shooting
tennis balls just launching around the
puppies are gonna [ __ ] do backflips
all day anywhere could be lunch time in
a [ __ ] tennis ball philosophy there
they're gonna have to decide yes prime
rib or tennis ball yeah they make their
own choices man and so this gonna be a
beautiful place in is just in Florida
and you're gonna be there sometimes or
how does it go I'm gonna damn near live
there I love that you're the rat for
rebar you gonna [ __ ] roll around and
tell him what's going on I love that
you're gonna be there too
dude I'll be there could I work there so
I'll play two weeks out of a year man I
want to whistle to it like a quiet
whistle don't nothin had do whatever you
want dude I would love that man wasn't
working the gift shop
didn't have a gift shop too with the a
well you know I gonna NFL with the the
cooling fans blow snow out and that's
everywhere
damn I love that man snow he sweats five
hours yeah
damn is that sweat that's [ __ ]
snowboards gloss this summertime that's
sports gloss that lost balls let's play
another we got another question that
came in here let's get into another one
year yo what up Theo whatever if ref is
your boy Dustin coming at you from Texas
a big fan of both you guys my question
is what is your favorite sports player
from the late 80s Early 90s I gotta say
miles probably Bo Jackson so let me know
what you guys think gang gang gang gang
ma'am
that's a go mime represent to mine
sports immense so many I'm AI proud to
have to say probably Dion Sanders
I remember I think it was when he got
drafted and he was had nugget gold
jewelry and he had a mullet yes yeah
look at me he had the Cray the glasses
he wasn't playing no he was he was he
looked good he played good and got
backing up and he was about sports and
about winning he showed up as a good
doing it he should have praised Deion
Sanders yeah bo Jackson's another one
I heard they put a weight bench in his
house to make you so when Scouts would
come through they think he worked up I
don't think he ever touched away a day
in his life and he was a legend and he
was one of a kind I'm trying to think of
anybody else that I tried to be there
weren't any I mean Michael Jack no he
said baseball huh or did he he said
sports and Michael Jack I mean obviously
Michael Jordan was rare there wasn't a
lot of Pistol Pete Maravich was man I
worry
I watched the that movie you ever seen
is his we are the the pissed I think
yeah yeah what about him growing up he
dribble basketball well I used to do
that
dribble attendance ball dribble
basketball just anything where the
basketball down where holes in my shoes
you remember gold for walking
neighborhood in a ball with you man you
take it everywhere yeah if somebody saw
you drooling bethlo he's a basketball
player yeah oh he's going he's always
trying out next year they're gonna know
what I'm doing yeah you're gonna see
what I'm about they driving by they
don't think you're not about nothing I'm
about basketball yeah I'm about [ __ ]
hoops [ __ ] you know what I'm saying
everywhere I'll [ __ ] hoop on your
whole family I got a two-year-old in the
back he's looking at you flipped that
little [ __ ] dribble down the
damn cereal aisle and throw some Nabisco
treats yeah what that I don't want no
food I'm sports
I'll Dunkin Donuts on your neck bra
[ __ ] I'll give you a [ __ ] I'll give
you a cousin some dimetapp dude I don't
give a damn bro I'll put band-aids on
your grandmother bro
I don't give a [ __ ] man it was a
different time man different you had to
be about something yeah remember that
you had to pick something and do it and
that's what you're about now people just
everybody
like I'm gonna rapper out all right this
is like a club right you go to you go
you got to do a little hideaway duck out
of club it everybody start pouring in
there yeah hey man I'm out I'm out
everybody now this is okay what's what's
yeah it's turning a structure I don't
know what the hell is going on it's
turning it oh yeah this is turning estee
lauder
let's turn into it down so big ass
Walmart
yeah all right I'll be here now I'm
gonna show up at 120 yeah
when y'all y'all done they're not done
yet yeah I think there's something to
that man is showing up and everybody's
going let's get one more question that
came in man yo Theo which a boy Ryan
from Illinois born and raised baby
what's up I got a question for you and
the vanilla gorilla himself see I've
been trying to put on them baby and I'm
looking for all natural solutions eight
recipes Billy conforto I know you like
you and him we're doing on the side of
that Highway brother but I'm looking for
that natural solution gang bruh I see
steroids with my buddy he was a busboy
but he died but yeah he so natural
solution man you're in way better shape
than I am what's right now is that I
like it okay so me personally I'm about
hot like comfort and feeling like but I
gained too much weight up focus too much
on just building muscle and not caring
about just and you could get bigger by
just eating there everything you know I
mean but to if you want to feel good and
gain muscle strength straight I'm
learning that's stretching helps and
then but food is like 80% of your like
how you gonna feel okay you know what I
mean so what I'm trying to do now is I
met eat as much vegetable you if you eat
a stir fry pan of just broccoli that's
what that has protein in it okay I mean
that I'm eating a - they have these new
tuna fish packets uh-huh and you tear
them open to mix some chopped up some
pickles and if I eat like 2 or 3 packs
of that tuna fish
that's me personally and consistently
drinking water so you get that pump you
feel good water vegetables low carb high
protein a lot of water it
sound it's it's it's like cliche because
that's obvious but when you really when
you repeatedly just do that do that do
that for days you start waking up with
more energy and you want to work out
more you feel so once you can get to
that stage where you actually want to
work out more and you realize oh it's
like putting gas in your car you don't
put it take a Snickers Warren smashed
into your gas tank it has to be gas
that's me pure gas yes and you came for
some corn nuts and that's like oh well
there's a way to tear some [ __ ]
Hawaiian Punch the green kind let me see
what this does
yeah you can't do that it has to be gas
so like your body is just like it
requires a certain thing and I know
right now what I'm starting to do is be
like okay if we were a hundred years ago
you know AC just got invented recently
you know I mean like process the process
food where I got if it didn't if if I
was like I think about if I was a
caveman was this around so fruits
vegetables you know I mean of pistachios
almonds you know I mean even like me
like I said not to eat me because I'm
just like it had to be a ok man looking
at like a lion tearing tearing apart of
deer and be like I guess I'll try that
right somebody's eating if they're
eating it if that lion is strong and
he's eating that then I should have been
so mad in that caveman walking up and
taking a chunk out of that fly ridden
[ __ ] deer and they eat that ain't you
know I mean then you have to add fired
like but it imagine being way back in
the day and then you find a [ __ ] Kiwi
you're like what the [ __ ] is this
tarantula but yeah you looking at sliced
open you're eating that imagine and that
tastes good to us today yeah so imagine
like back in there like yeah ok this is
these are like these are [ __ ] hidden
gems yeah and they have vitamins and
fruits and it's real you know I'm sad so
I'm trying to like beyond like fruits
and you're thinking of things that are
real things that somebody could find if
they're high if they're back in the day
they can find yeah and I think that's
what we're supposed to eat I thought it
was hidden like [ __ ] clues in the
world and you just have to find them but
if yours to focus on some [ __ ] then
you aren't gonna be thinking like that
and like you're putting the [ __ ] in you
yeah it's how you feel it's how you
think it's how you see it's how you you
know I mean do you think your diet
affects the way that you think hell yeah
if you aren't in a good mood and if you
physically like imagine
hungover mm-hmm if you're hungover you
can't think about what how your dog
feels you can't think about how your
friends feel your if you have a
girlfriend what you can't think about
they just make me feel better I need to
feel better you yes yeah I guess I mean
you're you're you're thinking you're
thinking inward yeah when you can when
you think clear and your that's why I
want to work out early the more your
blood flow and blood gets your brain
like okay I'm ready for the day I'm good
yeah you know what I mean you get that
blood flowing you get thinking clearly
then you give off a whole different
radiation yeah yeah that's what I'm
going towards I'm not there yet I'm just
I take little bits of pieces to
everybody I see or that everybody does
and now I'm like you can't do everything
that somebody says no I don't want to
give advice to somebody I could but I
could tell you what I'm doing right now
yeah
and that's what I'm in right now yeah
your experience here you can all share
your experience yeah that's one thing
I've kind of learned over time is yeah
sometimes I try to be careful with my
ego you know it's like I try to just
because ego can be so dangerous you know
it's not right if you think you're
thinking inward you have to outward yeah
you can't think about [ __ ] too much yeah
yeah and then I have more fun to when I
started really getting stuck on myself
or stuck on what's going on I finally
get negative I scour operate from a
place of fear you know I mean you got a
you do and that's why I wanna if you can
get yourself feeling good you're like oh
this is good hair blowing in the wind
riding a bike you'd like okay
yeah lip in the four-wheeler Ralph
DeSimone ahead right riding that bike
dude
one of the neighbors looked at me like I
might steal something I'm like [ __ ] she
didn't want away if I had to wave it
yeah I saw you [ __ ] start that wave
change their vibe up hey how you doing
she gave a little one to you yeah she
had waved at the other guy in the car hi
ash you try to scurry out nine now you
you gonna wave oh you gonna wave him oh
yeah he gonna way baby
Waverly Estates yeah welcome welcome to
the way fool yeah you know what I'm
saying this the deep end yeah you gonna
join the way yeah you gonna like it
yeah by this afternoon he won't be doing
this your scheana wants if she hated -
yeah yeah
pesky he's riding a four-wheeler those
hater waves man all right did you keep a
Yong I can't wait to see this dog park
man I can't wait to come and work at it
I'm gonna be the lifeguard in the in the
puppy pool whatever you want if they
piss in it I don't care if I'm gonna
look the other way
salt water and Laffy Taffy salt salt
water taffy is over there free salt
water taffy everybody's gonna be a
cooling the cabana some barbecue because
people love their pets so much they
would love it man it's a whole different
vibe being around animals versus they
don't ask for clothes they don't ask for
our instagrams yeah I don't care about
another [ __ ]
they're rockin fur coats trampling
around all day all they wanted some hugs
and [ __ ] lunch meat yeah that's
beautiful hugs and ham dude that's that
[ __ ] ham hocks then ham hocks brought
it away to someone's heart
riff-raff man thank you so much and I'm
so grateful that Simon uh you know he
hooked us up yo Cassatt yeah somewhere
along the line because I love you man he
was the first one to show me you you
know me yeah yeah he's always like yeah
he's a he is always on some new [ __ ]
he's always on the health [ __ ] yeah he
always looks the same yeah you know I
mean same 7% body fat the last 30 years
yeah now he's always on like the next
thing and that he's somebody else was a
very influential just in real life you
know I mean ya know man he's the one who
gave he's only I remember he told me but
he was are way more credit than he
should be to me he should be in so many
movies yeah
you know I mean we yeah he should I mean
also he stays so busy though I think he
definitely is don't always get another
one he's not successful successful ain't
easy and you just got that mobile home
sweet traveler he's always on some [ __ ]
yeah he's on his own thing and that man
and Ollie me too
he's the one man uh but dude it's an
honor and I really appreciate you
letting us be here today man
alright I'm glad to have you your first
human in here I know that's cold
yeah yeah man as opposed to me Mike
pleasure to meet Ari oh I gotta get your
Barbara give me a one-line cut yeah
let's get him with a one the one line he
got a UH just cuz it's my first time
here I'll get one long yeah give me one
line in will not you up to next time
next time gang bra you can get that
Versace veteran level with the three oh
wow yeah that's that's at the dog park
yeah I might need to read it up of Green
Arrow read the handbook on that one for
of Eclipse good we'll get it in rip
thank you so much Matthew I really
appreciate it appreciate
[Music]
I'll share this piece of thought it's
gonna take
a little time for me to set that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]